J. MICHAEL MCBRIDE: OK, so we've
been
talking about electrophilic
addition and the nucleophilic
aspect of it.
Today we'll extend that to talk
about cycloaddition and
also there'll be some practical
applications with
respect to epoxides and acetals
and how they work.
So first, about that problem I
gave you last time, about
drawing nice curved arrows to
show the pinacol
rearrangement.
So, how does it start out?
What's the first thing that
happens?
Wells, do you have an idea for
acid catalysis here?
What's the very first thing that
happens?
Too early in the morning?
Chris, what do you say?
STUDENT: The proton protonates.
PROFESSOR: Protonates what?
STUDENT: Probably OH.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So we'll protonate the OH, and
then water can leave. Why is
it good for water to leave,
Chris?
STUDENT: The pKa of hydronium is
low,
negative.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, O3+
[correction: H3O+]
is good at losing things, how
about the other aspect of it?
How about the thing that's
leaving, other than the water?
STUDENT: It's charged?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, how about where
the charge goes?
STUDENT: Away.
PROFESSOR: What's it going to be
when the water leaves?
The water will be neutral.
Pardon me.
STUDENT: It will go from a
positive charge to a neutral
charge in this case.
PROFESSOR: The water will, but
we care about the organic
thing more than about the water.
What will be left?
STUDENT: Negative charge.
PROFESSOR: No, no.
The thing is a cation, if you
lose neutral water,
the charge will stay.
Where will it be?
STUDENT: On the carbon.
PROFESSOR: Is that a good place
for it to be?
STUDENT: Yes.
PROFESSOR: Why?
Why is that good?
STUDENT: It's tertiary.
PROFESSOR: It's tertiary.
All right, so we get a nice
tertiary cation.
What did anybody think about the
next step here?
Yeah, Kate.
STUDENT: I thought that maybe
there was a methide shift.
PROFESSOR: A methide shift,
good.
So the methide could shift over,
a rearrangement, and now
you have this cation.
Now, Kate, you're going to tell
me about this cation.
We started already with a very
good cation, a tertiary
cation, right, that's as good as
they get with--
unless you have double bonds
next door.
OK.
But, what's the driving force?
Why should it go this direction?
What's good about being on the
right?
STUDENT: It has to do with the
fact the CO
bond is a low LUMO.
PROFESSOR: No, I don't think you
could say
the CO, it's true--
the CO bond is a lower LUMO.
But to the extent that the
oxygen, the reason it's low is
because of the oxygen, right.
And, that oxygen is withdrawing
charge from the
carbon, withdrawing electrons
from the carbon, tending to
make the carbon positive anyhow.
So, if a carbon is already
positive, it's not such a
great place to put more positive
charge.
So, to the extent that that
sigma bond is important, you'd
think it'd go the other
direction.
The oxygen would be electron
withdrawing and destabilize
the cation.
Can anybody see why it could be
good to have
the oxygen next door?
It's certainly not that sigma
bond.
STUDENT: Isn't the unshared pair
the reason?
PROFESSOR: What about the
unshared pair?
STUDENT: They stabilize the
positive charge.
PROFESSOR: You know actually, I
would say
the other way around.
The electrons are something
real, right, and they get
stabilized by mixing with the
low vacant orbital that's
associated with the positive
charge.
It's the electrons that get
lower in energy.
OK, but you're absolutely right,
so you can draw a
resonance structure like that,
and that's why it's good to go
to the right.
OK, now, how do you get from
there to the product?
Jack?
STUDENT: Hydrogen can go off.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, you just lose a
proton, right, and you've
got the product.
So, that's the mechanism of the
pinacol rearrangement.
It's all steps that you know
well, but you have to think
and put them together, so that's
just
an exercise in that.
OK, now back to these
simultaneous reactions that
are involved in addition to
alkenes.
Simultaneous in the sense that
there's both electrophile,
which is what they're typically
called,
electrophilic additions, but,
also a nucleophile that's
participating at the same time.
We saw this last time with
dichlorocarbene which you
remember came on edge on, and
then rotated in order to make
the two new bonds to give us
cyclopropane.
We saw it in hydroboration,
where the vacant orbital on
the B attacks, but at the same
time the high HOMO B-H, mixes
with the pi-star orbital.
OK, so, now we're going to go on
to a different kind of a
way of making a cyclopropane
with what's called the
Simmons-Smith reagent, and then
into epoxidation, adding
just an oxygen to a double bond
to give us 3-membered
oxirane ring, and then
ozonolysis which is a more
dramatic kind of cycloaddition
to give a ring, and then we
probably won't get today to
catalytic hydrogenation, and
to polymerization and
metathesis,
where metals are involved.
So, we'll do those others today.
First, the so called
Simmons-Smith
reagent or a carbenoid.
We talked about CCl2, a carbene,
last time, that's a
free species, it's pretty
reactive, but it floats free.
It has an existence.
These are called carbenoids,
because they don't really give
a free carbene, but they give a
product as if it were a
carbene, that is the CH2 in a
3-membered ring.
The reagents as you can see, are
methylene iodide, CH2I2,
and the thing called zinc-copper
couple, and I
don't know where the name couple
came from except that
there two metals there.
But it, turned out that having a
little copper with the zinc
made it work better.
So, I don't know, anyhow, zinc
is the operative group here,
but copper clearly has something
to do with it.
This was developed at DuPont
Central Research in
Wilmington, Delaware, where
Howard Simmons was the
Director of Research.
First, a word about metals and
alkyl halides.
So, you have a metal and an
alkyl halide.
Now, metals tend to be over on
the left of the periodic
table, what does that mean about
their electrons?
Are the highest valence
electrons held tightly or are
they able to give up electrons?
Compared to most things.
Do they have a high HOMO?
Things that are on the left of
the periodic table don't have
such a big nuclear charge, given
the row they are in, so
they're relatively good at
giving up electrons.
How about RX?
What makes it reactive, a halide
on R?
What's its characteristic
reactivity?
Ayesha.
STUDENT: Low LUMO, sigma-star.
PROFESSOR: Low LUMO, sigma-star.
So, we have something that can
give electrons and something
that can take it, so it won't
surprise you that you can get
an electronic transfer from the
metal, and it's just a
metallic metal, it's not an ion
in
solution, it's just a metal.
But, at the surface of the metal
an electron could be
transferred to RX.
Now, where does that electron go
in the RX?
Ayesha, you got us on to this,
tell us again, what orbital
does it go into?
STUDENT: Sigma-star.
PROFESSOR: And what does star
mean?
STUDENT: Antibonding.
PROFESSOR: That it's
antibonding.
So, what's, going to happen when
you put an
electron and get RX-?
It's also a radical, it's got an
odd number of electrons.
What's the role of that last
electron?
What does the star mean?
STUDENT: Antibonding.
PROFESSOR: Antibonding.
What happens?
We put electrons in the
antibonding orbital,
what does it do?
STUDENT: Breaks.
PROFESSOR: Right, breaks the
bond.
So, a pair will go there, and
now you got
X- and the R radical.
But, the R radical is generated
right next to the
metal, so you can get a making
of a bond between that radical
and an atom in the metal.
OK.
So, you get an alkyl-metal bond
and X-.
This is shown as if the metal is
divalent, like zinc, so it
makes a bond to R, and has a
positive charge, and then it's
associated with the X-.
If it had been a monovalent
metal like lithium, then it
wouldn't have had the charge, it
would be RLi, right.
Two lithium atoms would have
been involved.
Another one would be Li+ that
goes with X-, but at any rate,
this is how you make alkyl-metal
bonds
in the first place.
The next three slides suggest a
plausible mechanism for this
formation of the cyclopropane,
but as we'll see, it's
probably not correct.
But, let's just take this as an
opportunity to practice
figuring out how mechanisms
might work.
So, we could react zinc with
methyl chloride, and we get
this reaction that was shown on
the bottom of the previous
slide, a metal-zinc bond and
chloride, and I've shown it
covalent between the chloride
and the zinc. We
showed +/- last time.
This we're going to use as a
model for the actual reaction,
which had CH2I2 as the starting
material with zinc.
So, it gave I-Zn-CH2I, so we've
simplified it here so we
can draw orbitals that are a
little simpler.
That's the LUMO of that model
compound and mostly it's a 4s
orbital on the zinc, which is
antibonding to the things on
either side, which take away
part of it, because you have
antibonding nodes there, of
course.
So, that's the LUMO.
The HOMO is mostly a p orbital
on the zinc,
actually the LUMO+1.
Now, if you bend the zinc,
you'll mix those
two, they'll hybridize.
So, if you bend it, that's the
4p on zinc, if you bend it, as
it's approaching the transition
state, where the
zinc is going to be approaching
the C-C double
bond, then you hybridize that
central one and you've got an
orbital that looks like this.
And, that's an sp hybrid, sp
something or other on the
zinc. Notice that that's the
LUMO, so what's it well set up
to do with respect to the
alkene?
What could it overlap with?
Amy?
STUDENT: The sigma bond HOMO
PROFESSOR: Sigma is down in the
middle of the carbons.
STUDENT: Wouldn't the pi be
better?
PROFESSOR: The pi is sticking up
where
you need it to overlap.
So that can overlap with the
HOMO, and you're going to get
a pair of electrons that's
bonding between these two
things, between the zinc and the
two carbons.
But, this is again one of those
cases, so we have an
electrophile on top, a LUMO,
attacking an alkene, but we
can also look at the HOMO on
top, that's the electrons
shifting into the bonding
region.
We can also look at the HOMO on
top, and what does that
look well set up to do?
Matt, what do you say, with
respect to the alkene?
What orbital of the alkene could
that react with?
STUDENT: The double bond, I
guess.
PROFESSOR: What about the double
bond?
Which specific orbital of the
double bond?
STUDENT: The pi-star.
PROFESSOR: pi-star, right, which
is the vacant orbital,
which is what you want.
This a HOMO, the LUMO downstairs
is what we want
there, and you see those are
well set up to react.
We can do electron donation in
the other direction, top to
bottom, right, so were taking an
electron pair from top to
bottom, also previous slide,
bottom to top, so we're
forming two new bonds.
We can draw curved arrows, like
this and like that, and
what we've done now is form this
product where zinc is
added at one side and methyl at
the other.
Now, remember this we just drew
so the orbitals would
look simpler.
If we had been using that thing
that had two iodines
instead of one chlorine, then
the product would have been
this, within the same reaction,
but that would have
been the product.
And now, what makes this
reactive?
Can you see where there might be
a low LUMO in this?
Any ideas?
Cassie?
STUDENT: The sigma-star orbital
of the C-l.
PROFESSOR: Sigma star in the
carbon-halogen bond.
That would be a low LUMO.
How about the HOMO?
Where would be an unusually high
HOMO?
Carbon with a halogen is
unusually low, what's the
analog that's unusually high?
Carbon with what?
STUDENT: The zinc atom.
PROFESSOR: With a metal is
unusually high.
So, the carbon-zinc bond would
be unusually high.
Sigma Zn-C, and the LUMO is
sigma-star C-Cl.
I left one of the C's out.
Can you see what can happen?
So, you have a high HOMO
attacking a C-X bond, where
have we seen that before?
What reaction has a high HOMO
attack sigma-star C-X, where X
is a halogen?
STUDENT: Borohydration.
PROFESSOR: Pardon me?
PROFESSOR: I can't hear you.
STUDENT: Borohydration.
PROFESSOR: Hydroboration is such
a case and I'd have to
think about why this is an
example.
I had it even simpler example in
mind.
STUDENT: SN2.
PROFESSOR: SN2 right, a backside
attack by the high HOMO.
We can have the HOMO attack the
carbon, the iodide is the
leaving group.
That then would form the
3-membered ring.
So that's a very plausible
mechanism, it has two steps.
First, you have the addition of
zinc halide and the carbon
group, and then in a second
step, you do the SN2 type
reaction to form the second
bond.
The first reaction formed the
bond on the right between the
two CH2's and the second
reaction formed this one.
But that probably is not the way
it goes.
It's probably not two transition
states.
We just guessed that.
There was a quantum mechanical
calculation of what the
transition state for this should
look like and they
found something different.
Although that mechanism is
plausible, it probably occurs
in a single step according to
this calculation, with this
bent transition state.
This is the transition state
where everything is happening
at once, and let's look at what
that is.
First, we could look at how the
thing moves through the
transition state.
You see, the carbons going
closer, the iodine is going
away from the carbon, and the
zinc going away.
Let's see what happens.
Notice incidentally that the CH2
group is like this, and is
rocking in.
Where have you seen that before?
Where the CH2 group approaches
sideways and then rocks in?
Seen that before?
Ellen?
STUDENT: The carbene with
chlorines.
PROFESSOR: A true carbene, CCl2
did exactly that in order
to get the orbitals to match up.
Let's look at the orbitals in
the transition state for this
on the way to making the
cyclopropane.
This is at the transition-state
geometry.
Here's the LUMO.
What is that LUMO of the zinc
reagent?
What would you call that
orbital?
STUDENT: Sigma-star.
PROFESSOR: Sigma-star between
zinc and the iodine.
That's the LUMO, and you can see
it's well set up to mix
with the pi HOMO.
At the same time, this is the
HOMO-2.
It's very near the HOMO, so a
very high-energy orbital.
What's that well set up to
overlap with?
Matt, you're our expert on this?
What about the alkene is well
set up there?
STUDENT: The pi-star.
PROFESSOR: pi-star, right.
Blue on the right, red on the
left.
We can do both of them at once
and make the two new bonds and
break the others.
Here's the next reaction we want
to talk about, which is
an analogous reaction in the
sense of forming two bonds at
once with a reaction between an
alkene and a
percarboxylic acid .
If we didn't have the red oxygen
there, if that hydrogen
were directly attached to the
oxygen below, that group would
be a carboxylic acid.
This is called the peracid, per-
means two oxygens linked
together, which is of course not
a very stable bond.
Do you remember why it's not so
stable to have two
oxygens in a row?
Natalie?
STUDENT: Repulsion between the
electrons.
PROFESSOR: You have two pairs of
electrons that are
repelling one another across the
bond.
So, meta-chloroperbenzoic acid
is a commonly used reagent for
this, and the product, you see,
gives the more stable carboxylic
acid, and oxygen attached to the
double bond.
Our question is what the
mechanism is.
It's also interesting to wonder
why you use
meta-chloroperoxybenzoic acid.
Why meta?
Why not para?
It just seems a weird choice.
It's interesting why it's
chosen.
It's because it crystallizes
very easily, and the crystals
of it are very stable, so it
could be stored for a very
long time without any
decomposition, even though
essentially it's a rather
unstable compound.
It's that practical application
that means that
this particular one is the one
that's often chosen, although
others could be used as well,
other R groups on the peroxy
acid functionality.
OK, so you see in this
particular case which I took
as an example from the Jones
book, it was done at 25
degrees in benzene for five
hours and gave an 81% yield
when R is n-hexyl, so it's a
pretty good reaction.
So, to look at what the orbitals
are involved, let's
just make that R group instead
of meta-chlorobenzene, make it
just the hydrogen, so this is
peroxyformic acid, where the
extra oxygen is obviously here.
Had that hydrogen been here, it
would
have been formic acid.
Let's just distort that to the
geometry it has at the
transition state.
So you see the oxygen-oxygen
length increased a little bit,
and the hydrogen bent up a bit.
Now we'll rotate it, so to get
the idea of how we're going to
look at it and rotate it back a
bit.
Now we're going to look at the
orbitals it has, it has a
bunch of occupied orbitals, of
course.
And, it has a bunch of
unoccupied orbitals.
But, we're particularly
interested in its LUMO.
What's the LUMO going to be?
Elisa, what do you think?
There're several possibilities,
so come
up with anything.
Anybody else got an idea, Karl?
STUDENT: Sigma-star O-O.
PROFESSOR: Sigma-star O-O.
Remember, that's an oxygen,
big nuclear charge.
Can you see any other thing that
might be a low LUMO?
Karl?
STUDENT: Pi-star of C-O.
PROFESSOR: Pi-star of C-O is
also low.
So in principle, either of those
might be the reaction.
So, that's really the problem
often in choosing mechanisms,
that there's several
possibilities, and you have to
consider them all, and if
they're two possibilities, and
then at the next step two more,
and two more, it gets to
be a pretty big number.
But at any rate, those are the
two that you might consider at
the beginning and once you've
tried these several paths,
then you can see which one's
going to give you the product
that you know by experiment is
actually the product, and it
turns out to be this one,
sigma-star O-O. How about the
LUMO of this thing?
Pardon me, that was the LUMO,
here's the HOMO, actually it's
not the HOMO, it's the HOMO-3,
but do you see
what it's made of?
What's this big thing here?
STUDENT: Unshared pairs.
PROFESSOR: That's the p orbital
on oxygen, the
unshared pair, and it's mixed
with this up here, which
notice is three p orbitals in a
row.
So that's a p orbital on this
oxygen and the pi electrons of
the C-O double bond, mixing
together in a bonding way here
but antibonding here.
That's why had this been red and
that been blue, then this
would have been a lower energy
orbital, so this is the
antibonding combination of those
two, and it
happens to be HOMO-3.
So that's the HOMO that we're
going to be interested in.
So that's mostly, as we said,
the pi on that oxygen, the p
orbital, and also pi-allyllic.
Remember allyllic is three p
orbitals in a row all pointing
in the same direction so they
overlap side to side.
And there we've turned it a
little further just so you can
see that it's those p orbitals.
Now we're going to look at it as
it interacts with the
carbon-carbon double bond.
The first interaction is going
to be that LUMO of the
oxygen-oxygen bond, sigma-star,
that's the
electrophile, that's the LUMO,
and the high occupied orbital is
going to be our old favorite, pi
of the double bond.
We'll do this.
What does that reaction remind
you of a little bit, when
something comes in from one
side, and the group leaves with
its electrons from the other
side?
SN2 of course, so it's the same
kind of reaction.
So that's an SN2 attacking
oxygen, not carbon of course.
So, that's going to form a new
bond, and the leaving group,
notice, is a fairly good anion,
carboxylate, better than RO-.
Now, what makes this reactive?
What could happen next?
Elisa?
STUDENT: You have a positive
charge on the carbon.
PROFESSOR: We've got a positive
charge on carbon, so
that's going to be a very low
energy orbital there.
Where could be a HOMO that would
react with that?
A high occupied orbital.
Liang?
STUDENT: The lone pair on
oxygen.
PROFESSOR: OK, it could be.
That wasn't what I expected you
to say, that's going to be
what it is.
What other possibility?
Liang?
[LAUGHTER]
Liang, what other possibility is
there when you look at this
picture for a high HOMO?
STUDENT: The negative charge on
the--
PROFESSOR: Right, we got a
negative charge up here.
This oxygen looks to me like it
has a higher HOMO
than this one does.
What advantages does yours have
over the
one that's up there?
STUDENT: It's closer.
PROFESSOR: Pardon me?
PROFESSOR: It's closer, right.
The electrophile is going to be
what Elisa said, the p
orbital on the carbon plus.
But, the p orbital on the oxygen
is going to be the
nucleophile, and it has the
advantage of being nearby.
So that means we can do this and
make a second bond, and of
course the plus charge will move
when
we share the electrons.
Now, what do we have for a LUMO
here?
If we're going to do another
reaction?
It's something to do with a
positive charge.
What particular orbital would
you point to, if we had to
choose a particular orbital?
The charge is not an orbital.
The charge makes an orbital low,
makes the electrons in an
orbital, low in energy nearby.
But, what orbital will we look
at?
Jack, you got an idea?
STUDENT: Pi.
PROFESSOR: Pardon me.
PROFESSOR: I couldn't hear.
STUDENT: Pi.
PROFESSOR: Which pi?
STUDENT: The one with oxygen.
PROFESSOR: A p orbital on
oxygen?
The p orbitals on oxygen are all
filled with electrons.
We're looking for a vacant
orbital, right?
It's true that the unshared pair
on oxygen is lower in
energy than it would normally
be, but that
doesn't make it reactive.
For a pair of electrons to be
reactive they have to be high
in energy, not low.
We want some vacant orbital that
will be
unusually low in energy.
Chris?
STUDENT: d orbital?
PROFESSOR: The d orbital?
No, you know, if you get to
sulfur or something, if you
get down in the next row of the
periodic table, then there
are d orbitals that are vacant
in the valence shell, but on
oxygen d is way up in the next
shell.
STUDENT: Sigma-star.
PROFESSOR: Sigma-star.
STUDENT: of C-O?
PROFESSOR: It could be sigma
star C-O. Any other
possibilities?
It could be sigma-star C-O. Any
other possibilities?
STUDENT: Sigma-star O-H.
PROFESSOR: Sigma-star O-H.
Right.
That's the kind of thing you're
thinking of, because
when you have an O+ that's
protonated, three bonds, one
of them to a proton, what do you
think of happening?
Losing a proton, right, and
that's that sigma-star O-H. So
that's going to be our
electrophile, that's where the
electrons are going to go, into
sigma-star O-H
and break that bond.
Where they going to come from?
Where's the high HOMO?
Liang, let's go back to you now.
STUDENT: Negative charge.
PROFESSOR: Now you've got the
negative charge here.
But there's something
interesting about this
negative charge.
The reason that was a good place
to put a negative
charge, that carboxylate was a
good leaving group, was that
there was a carbonyl group, a
C-O double bond next door.
We can denote that--
so we're going to have an SN2 at
H. We're going to attack,
and notice where we're going to
attack from, backside.
These attacks are always
backside to break a
sigma-star.
Now, the trouble with this O- is
that it's not backside,
it's out in the front.
Can you see how we could get it
into the back?
How could we get this charge
back near here?
One way that Karl suggests is
move the anion, it's not
bonded after all.
But, there's a cleverer way to
do it.
Not that you're not clever,
Karl.
Watch this.
Does that suggest anything?
That's why carboxylate is a good
leaving group, because
it's resonance-stabilized.
But, what does that suggest?
Sebastian?
You don't need to use this
anion, you can use this anion,
because the charge is both
places here.
So we can draw that, put the
charge over there, and a
double bond here in front.
So now we've got it where it
needs to be. Now we can do the
backside attack, move the proton
over.
We have those products, the
carboxylic acid without it's
oxygen, that extra oxygen that
the peracid had, and oxygen
added to the carbon-carbon
double bond to give a
3-membered ring, an oxirane as
it's called, or an epoxide.
The interesting thing about
this--
Karl had the great idea, let's
just move it to
where it needs to be.
But there's a reason I didn't
want to move things.
The reason is, that in fact, all
those steps are not steps.
They all happen at the same
time.
So in fact when you start with
that material, and bring it up
to the carbon-carbon double
bond, all those
things happen at once.
It made sense looking at them
one at a time, but in fact
they can all happen at the same
time.
So you have minimal atomic
displacement if you go
directly from this to transfer
the oxygen atom and get that.
But, they don't happen strictly
in parallel, just
because they're all happening at
the same time, doesn't mean
that they're all half way done
at the same time.
Some are a little leading, some
are a little trailing,
but they're all happening
together with
minimal atomic motion.
How do I know that?
Because of this paper that was
published in JACS in 1991.
Now that's 20 years ago, and you
can do much better
calculations I'm sure now.
But, this is when it was done
and published and it's
believable.
This is what they calculated for
the geometry at the
transition state, and they give
in every case what the
length of that bond, and what
the bond angles are.
Notice that that O-O is strongly
stretched at the
transition state, so it's really
broken a lot, putting
the electrons in the anti-bond.
It's started to break, it's
1.87, where normally it was
1.5, roughly.
Notice that the O-H bond,
remember that H is going to
transfer from O1 to O3, at the
transition state it is hardly
stretched at all.
It started at about one angstrom
and it's 1.01 here at
the transition state.
It actually is going to do most
of its motion after the
transition state.
I put KH/KD is about one, that
is there's not a kinetic
isotope effect on this.
Does that surprise you that
there's not a
kinetic isotope effect?
That deuterium and hydrogen are
transferred at the same rate?
What does it tell you, when
there's a hydrogen isotope
effect, a hydrogen-deuterium
isotope effect?
What does that tell you about
the mechanism, about the
transition state?
STUDENT: That it's an
intermediate.
PROFESSOR: No, it doesn't tell
you, it's an intermediate.
STUDENT: That the deprotonation
is
the limiting step.
PROFESSOR: The rate limiting
step, the hydrogen is being
transferred, not before, not
after, but at the rate
limiting step.
But, in this case, the bond
isn't much stretched at the
transition state, so there's not
an isotope effect, because
most of the transfer of the
hydrogen is happening later.
This shows the motion,
successive motions.
Here's the transition state,
then P1, P2 are subsequent
stages on the reaction pathway.
If you look at the motion of
each atom, you see the
hydrogen does most of its motion
from this oxygen to
this oxygen after the transition
state.
So, just because all these
things are coordinated, you
don't have distinct
intermediates, you have only
one transition state, but they
don't all have to be 50% of
the way from starting material
to product at
exactly the same instant.
You can see how the others are
moving as well.
So, notice that after the
transition state, the
hydrogens are moving down a
little bit, the carbons are
moving up, the oxygen is moving
in here to make the new
bond, and so on, and the
hydrogen is moving away.
This thing, the carboxylate at
the top is rocking away,
breaking the oxygen-oxygen bond
here, and
forming the OH bond here.
There's only one transition
state, this is said to be
concerted in the sense things
are happening at the same
time, not several distinct
intermediates.
But it's not synchronous, it's
not all
happening exactly in parallel.
The name of this transition
state, they called it spiro
transition state.
Spiro means two perpendicular
rings sharing a common atom.
Here it's O1, here's this
five-membered ring here, and a
three-membered ring here, but
they're perpendicular to one
another, they share an atom.
That's what spiro means, to have
two rings that are spiro,
they share an atom and are
perpendicular to one another.
But, in fact, a very similar
mechanism, in fact arguably
the same mechanism, was proposed
by Professor
Bartlett, your grandfather, in
1950.
This was before people thought
so much about spiro and about
the arrangement in space of
orbitals as they do now.
In fact, they didn't think about
orbitals at
all really in 1950.
So, in a paper in 1950, he drew
this structure, which
shows the peroxycarboxylic acid
twisted around, so the
hydrogen can make it from here
to here, and the oxygen then
be transferred to that.
So this picture is taken from
that publication in 1950.
You'll notice that the arrows
were not at all carefully
drawn, and it's not clear what
they mean.
This hydrogen in fact started
attached to this oxygen, and
is now moved over to this oxygen
in the product, so I
have no idea really what that
arrow meant.
But, that was old days, right,
before people talked about
orbitals and so on, 60 years
ago.
The problem is, how about now,
how carefully do people draw
such things now?
Well, we could look at a modern
textbook that has a
drawing of this particular
reaction, and
draws it in that way.
What I'd like you to think of
for a problem is, compare the
arrows in this textbook
illustration, with the ones
that we developed in the
previous frame to show where
HOMOs and LUMOs were
interacting, and how electron
pairs were shifting, and see if
you can draw your own
diagram that's more accurate
than this textbook one is.
Stereospecificity of this
epoxidation, if the oxygen is
really being transferred this
way, all at once, the two new
bonds have to be on the same
face of the double bond.
So, if you started with
trans-2-butene and used this
meta-chloroperbenzoic acid, and
this is a specific example
done in this solvent, dioxane,
at 0
degrees for 10 hours.
Notice that these two methyl
groups are on opposite sides
of the 3-membered ring, just as
they were on opposite sides
of the pi bond here.
This happens with 52% to 60%
percent yield, but more
significant, is that it's
greater than 99.5% trans.
This is an actual 52% to 60%
yield, that's what they
actually got of pure stuff and
put it in the bottle.
And you know, that if you have
to distill stuff at the end
and so on, you don't always get
100%.
If all they had said, was that a
60% yield, you'd worry, what's
that other 40%?
Could it be the cis isomer?
In fact, that's not what it was,
because they tested and
found that there was no cis
there, it was more than 99.5,
the limits of their detection
was trans, so it's a concerted
syn addition, both new bonds
from the
same face of the alkene.
And, you'd worry about this
also, that this is the more
stable isomer, where the methyls
aren't running into
one another.
Maybe it wasn't specific, but
you just got the one that was
most stable.
So, of course what they did is
do the cis one as well, and
that's also greater than 99.5%,
cis now, not trans.
It's clear that the reaction is
stereospecific.
They did that in order to
prepare those epoxides for
another purpose.
It'd been prepared before, in
1936, by
an alternative mechanism.
It was two steps to do it, so it
was a
harder way to make it.
They started with the reagent
HOCl, hypochlorous acid.
How do you think HOCl will
react?
Any ideas?
What other reagent that we've
talked about reacting does
that remind you of?
This is a chlorine, with an
electronegative bond to it,
bond to oxygen.
What's the LUMO of that, do you
think?
Cassie?
STUDENT: The O-Cl sigma-star.
PROFESSOR: Right, O-Cl
sigma-star, the same as Cl-Cl
sigma-star.
What kind of thing happens with
Cl-Cl sigma-star
remember, if you react it with
an alkene?
It forms a halonium ion, like
that.
The only difference is that in
that case, it was Cl- that's
leaving, in this case it's OH-
that's leaving.
But, that's drawn in brackets
because it's just an
intermediate, it's not something
that you isolate,
it's very reactive.
Remember you made hydroxide, so
what's going to be the next
stage of the reaction.
How will this react with
hydroxide?
How does the one that had a
chlorine on
it react with chlorine?
It's an SN2 kind of reaction.
In fact, you have water here
that can also do it.
It gives a 55% yield after
distillation of this stuff,
where you notice what happened
was the oxygen attacked
backside, opened this ring.
So this methyl group is back,
and this methyl group is back,
since we started with cis.
We've got correlated
configurations
at these two carbons.
Notice it would have been just
as easy for the oxygen to
attack this carbon, it attacked
this one, it could
have attacked this one.
So it came this way, it could
have come this way.
What's the relationship between
the two products you
would get if you did those two
reactions?
Ellen?
STUDENT: Enantiomers.
PROFESSOR: They're enantiomers.
So you get not just this
compound, but also it's
enantiomer.
But, you don't get ones where
this methyl would be in front
of the hydrogen in back, as
shown there.
There are four diastereomers,
you only get two of them, you
get the two enantiomers.
So that's the first reaction,
they did it, they got a 55%
yield after distillation.
Then they reacted it with KOH,
notice it's 20 M KOH, pretty
strong solution at 90 degrees,
that's vigorous conditions, in
water for two hours.
How do you think OH- will react
with this stuff?
I want several possibilities.
What could OH- attack in this
molecule?
Chris?
STUDENT: Deprotonate the
hydrogen.
PROFESSOR: Deprotonate the
What would have been another
possibility?
STUDENT: Attack the chlorine.
PROFESSOR: It could've
attacked--
done an SN2 here on the other
one, but it's
a little bit hindered.
Generally proton transfers are
pretty fast, so you were right
the first time.
The KOH takes off that and
generates that anion.
Now again, I've drawn that in
brackets because it's just an
intermediate.
What does it do?
What does this O- do?
Chris, you just told me.
What can it attack?
STUDENT: The lone pair on the
oxygen.
PROFESSOR: It is the lone pair
on the oxygen, that's the high
HOMO, what's the low LUMO?
STUDENT: The sigma-star
carbon...
PROFESSOR: Yeah, sigma-star
carbon-chlorine.
What would you call that kind of
reaction, ever see a
reaction like that before, where
O- attacks carbon and
chloride leaves?
Noelle, did you ever see a
reaction like that?
STUDENT: SN2.
PROFESSOR: Can't hear.
PROFESSOR: It's SN2, right, and
it's helped out because
this is held very close to where
it needs to
be to do the reaction.
OK, so we do that.
Now, we form the epoxide.
Notice the stereochemistry of
this is interesting.
The two carbons are on the same
side of the ring, the
same way they were on the same
side of the pi bond here.
But, the stereochemistry
happened in sort of an
interesting way.
This is a 90% yield that they
got in this
in the second step.
But, since they had to do two
reactions from the starting
material, the overall yield was
only 45% from the original
starting material.
Do you remember what it was when
they used
meta-chloroperoxybenzoic acid in
the previous example to
make the same substance from the
same starting material?
You remember what the yield was?
STUDENT: 60%
PROFESSOR: Yeah, it was 60%.
So nearly half again as much, at
least a third again as
much, and in just one reaction,
you didn't have to
do this distillation and so on,
so it was much more
convenient.
That one, the oxygen just went
straight on, and
it was a syn addition.
This one happens in an
interesting way.
First, it's a syn addition of
the Cl+, both from the same
side, but then there's this SN2
kind of reaction, and it's
an inversion at this carbon.
And, then here, there's an
inversion at that carbon.
So overall, it's still a syn
addition, but by two
inversions.
So, that's interesting.
This is somewhat reminiscent of
what we talked about last
semester, which is the Sharpless
asymmetric
epoxidation.
I'll just run through this
quickly, we've done it several
times before.
So, you lose the RO-, then a
peroxy group comes up to the
titanium. We get that
intermediate and react it
with allyl alcohol.
The OH of the allyl alcohol
replaces the RO, it replaces
there, to get this.
And, now this double bond is
being held near this oxygen.
The LUMO is the sigma-star up
there, the same thing we've
been talking about, and the HOMO
is pi.
So, we've made a bond.
In fact, this pair of electrons
probably then makes
a bond between oxygen and this
titanium, rather than the RO
going away.
But, at the same time, there's
also the p on the oxygen
attacking pi-star of C-C. This
is exactly the same thing we
just saw a few slides ago with
peroxy benzoic acid.
We make two bonds, and put the
oxygen on from the same face.
This particular arrangement
makes the R configuration at
this tetrahedral carbon.
If we wanted to get the other
one, we'd have to rotate this
bond to be in front, and this to
be in back, so that we
could attack the other face,
rotate it back like that.
You'll notice that if you do
that, those two groups in
front are big, and they would
run into one another.
So you don't do that, you do the
other one, and it gives us
a specific enantiomer of the
epoxide.
But the relevance at this
stage--
that we talked about last
semester, the relevance at
this stage is that it's
essentially the same mechanism
that's involved in the
peroxybenzoic acid of the
electrons forming the two new
bonds.
That was a chiral oxidizing
agent.
Now, this is a big time--
making epoxides from alkenes is
really a big time
operation, as is shown here.
This is done with silver
catalysis at 15 atmospheres of
pressure and 250 degrees
Celsius.
Notice that the source of oxygen
is O2 in this case,
that's a really cheap source of
oxygen.
In fact, they do use O2.
There are other people who do
the same kind of thing who use
air, but it turns out to be
worthwhile to use O2 rather
than air, because you get a
higher yield.
So what you get is an oxygen
that's transferred like that,
that's called ethylene oxide.
That process generates 20
million tons a year, worth 20
billion dollars, of making
ethylene oxide.
Just to give you an idea, here's
an aerial view of New
Haven, and down here is where
most of you
live on the old campus.
If you had a bucket that would
hold that much ethylene oxide
as a liquid, it's a gas, but if
you condensed it, it would
be a liquid.
That's how big the bucket would
be.
[LAUGHTER]
I think it's 15 times as high as
Harkness Tower and covering
the entire old campus.
So, that's a lot of material.
Now that reaction gives 84%
yield, the rest oxidizes, the
rest of the original ethylene
oxidizes to CO2 and H2O.
Suppose you could adjust the
conditions to
make the yield higher.
Suppose instead of 84%, you
could increase it by 5%.
If you could raise the yield by
5%, that would be worth
more than a billion dollars a
year.
So, here's a way for you to make
your fortune.
Although, I will caution you
that people have worked on
this a lot to try to get every
last percentage out of it.
In fact, why make 20 million
tons of ethylene oxide?
Only 0.05% of it is used as
ethylene oxide.
It's a disinfectant that's used
in some applications,
it's a gas, and you can put it
in to
kill microbes or something.
But, very, very little of it is
used for.
What do they use it for?
2/3 of it is used to make that
compound, just add water in
the reaction that we were just
talking about,
to make that compound.
Does anybody know what that
compound is called?
You could call it
dihydroxyethane.
But, it has a more common name.
It's called ethylene glycol.
It's antifreeze.
So, a lot of it is used for
antifreeze, but it's also used
it for solvent.
Also it's incorporated in
polymers, the polyethylene
terephthalate, the stuff that
makes soft drink
bottles, for example.
It's used in making that.
Glycol is an interesting word.
The gly- is from Greek root that
means sweet, like
glucose, it's the same root.
It's because ethylene glycol
tastes sweet, although we
don't taste it because it's
poisonous, but the original
people did, so that's why it's
called glycol.
That reaction, to change
ethylene oxide into ethylene
glycol, occurs either with base
catalysis or acid
catalysis, so since the focus of
this lecture has been--
woops, this lecture is over.
Sorry, I got carried away.
We'll talk about the mechanisms
next time.
Thanks.